actually a guy named Matthew Charles was
there at the State of the Union he was
the first person to get out so that from
the first step back so that bill got out
thousands of people so we're working on
getting all of those people out now Kim
Kardashian is continuing to do good and
help people et has learned that she will
pay five years of a former inmates rent
after he was denied housing what's it
like to be free what's it like there is
unexpressable words and I mean it's
something I've been dreaming about for
close to 21 years now 22 years that's
Matthew Charles who was released from
prison in January after serving 20 years
of his 35 year sentence after being
convicted on nonviolent drug charges
since his release
NBC News learned he's also all about
giving back my heart is truly for the
poor for the homeless for those in
hearing me because people need to know
that they are loved no matter what their
situation but like other former inmates
he's had trouble finding a place to live
Kim saw mathy story and reached out to
his friend Tim Hartman offering to pay
five years of rent and contact any
property owners as a reference if needed
Hardiman tells ET quote when I told
Matthew about Kim's generous gift he was
overwhelmed he was truly humbled that
Kim was willing to lift that burden from
him Matthew told me Kim's generosity
will allow him to save enough money to
eventually put a down payment on his
first house Kim has changed his life
Hardiman also says Matthew will pay it
forward by helping others who are facing
the same obstacles he's endured now this
isn't the first time Kim has taken an
interest in prison reform she was also
instrumental in Alice Johnson's release
last year
I can I'm sorry I thought you knew oh my
god the news just broke to prep the
president just called me and he told me
that that you are out he signed the
papers it's been released to the press
everything and Kim isn't stopping there
she plans to do more with prison reform
but something that I really want to
focus on I think there's such a stigma
on people hiring formerly incarcerated
people so I would love to hire formerly
incarcerated people and I think I would
you know I would love to spread that
message that other companies and big
companies can do that too
okay I don't know about you guys but I
think it's so nice to see Kim using her
platform to do this type of work for all
the latest on the Kardashians make sure
that you are subscribed to all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krause and bye
for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]